amazon's upcoming middle-earth series is
set to take place in the second age
one of the least explored eras of
tolkien's myth and although these events
take place
thousands of years before the lord of
the rings there are still
many ways amazon's series could connect
to the original trilogy
one of the original rumors swirling
around amazon's series claimed that the
show would revolve around a young
aragorn
this was pretty exciting for tolkien
fans as aragorn's pre-lord of the ring
story is replete with romance
drama and action at a young age the king
in exile loses his father
spends decades wandering in the wild
fights alongside theodon's father and
rohan
saves gondor from an attack while in
disguise and falls in love with arwen
over the course of three long decades
the walking dead's tom payne stirred the
waters even more when he casually
mentioned that the amazon show was
casting
aragorn and then the news dropped that
the series would be set during the
second age
seemingly putting an end to any hopes of
seeing aragorn again
this is because although the ranger is
no spring chicken at 87 years young
during the events of the lord of the
rings
he's definitely not going to be walking
around many thousands of years earlier
but there is still one chance from day
one
it's been reported that amazon has the
rights to a spin-off series along with
their primary show
maybe it's there that fans will reunite
with the future king of gondor
gandalf's epic stand against the balrog
at the bridge of kaza doom
is one of the lord of the rings most
iconic scenes
and the ensuing duel on the peak of
silver teen really is a battle for the
ages
but while this fight has gone down in
literary and cinematic legend
it raises one important question just
where did this giant fire breathing
monster come from
fortunately the amazon show has a chance
to answer that very question
see back in the first age of middle
earth history
there were actually quite a few ball
rocks with tolkien himself suggesting
that there were
at most seven of these beasts running
around and causing havoc
most of them however were defeated and
killed during the war of
wrath at the end of the first stage as
the second age begins
one of the balrogs flees from this
catastrophe desperately searching for a
place to hide
eventually it decides that it will bury
itself deep in the subterranean
passages under the misty mountains near
the dwarven kingdom of kaza doom
there the creature would remain in cozy
anonymity for several thousand years
until far into the third age when the
dwarves would come across the last known
balrog during a mining expedition
you know what they awoke in the darkness
of hazard
shadow and flame
if amazon wants to connect their show to
the original trilogy
what better way than to follow the
origin story of durian's bane
the very balrog that would eventually
confront gandalf and the fellowship of
the ring
the elven lady galadriel has already
made her presence known in the lord of
the rings
and featured heavily in peter jackson's
hobbit trilogy too
but that's not particularly surprising
after all
galadriel is one of the oldest beings in
middle earth
clocking in at over 8 000 years old
during the original trilogy
of course that makes her an obvious
candidate to play a major role in the
amazon show
it's a fact that the studio clearly is
aware of too
since rumor has it that they already
cast the character
way back in late 2019. this will be an
excellent way to tie the original movies
in with the new streaming series
galadriel is a mover and a shaker
throughout the second age
showing up more than once and playing a
pivotal role in the forging of the rings
of power
but the production team can take
galadriel's role even further if they
want to
this is because during the second age of
middle earth galadriel visits lothlorien
for the first time
now that doesn't mean she gets her magic
mirror and becomes the lady of the
golden wood right there on the spot
but she does pay her first visit to the
woodland realm during the time that will
be depicted in the show
providing an easy and satisfying excuse
to take the audience on a stroll down
memory lane anyone who's familiar with
the lord of the rings will be very much
aware of the terrifying powers of the
witch king of angmar
the one who will lead more those armies
in war
the one they say no living man
can kill sauron's chief lieutenant is
the one who heads up the hunt for the
one ring
stabs frodo on weathertop leads mordor's
attack on ministerith
confronts gandalf at the gates of the
city and ultimately dies in an epic duel
with eowyn
from beginning to end the witch king
plays a pretty hefty role in the saga of
the third age
but the lord of the rings is just his
final act in truth
the witch king has a long and epic story
that stretches
way back into the second age in the
return of the king
gandalf refers to the witch king as
king of angmar long ago sorcerer
ringwraith lord of the nazgul
much of what gandalf is referencing here
harkens back thousands of years
to when sauron initially helped create
the rings of power during the second age
when the dark lord gave nine of these
rings to the great leaders of mortal men
the chief of these was the king of
angmar in the silmarillion
it's even stated that sauron was
particularly successful in ensnaring
three great lords of the numenorean race
and it's likely that one of these was
the witch king himself
considering it's been all but confirmed
at least some of amazon's series will
take place on numenor
it seems like it'd be more of a surprise
if the witch king
didn't show up when people think of
elrond
they typically picture a brooding elf a
grieving father
a ruminating counselor and generally a
bit of a downer
seriously though apart from a quick
scrape with nosgold and the hobbit
trilogy
and some flashy leadership in the intro
to the fellowship of the ring
elrond is typically portrayed on the
screen as a leader who doesn't
often get his hands dirty the thing is
though
by the time of the lord of the rings
elrond is thousands of years old
he was born at the end of the first age
and as it happened
played a very hands-on role in the
events of the second age
for example elrond is one of the few
people who sees through
sauron's disguise when he helps the
elves create the rings of power
he leads a portion of the armies that
initially fight against the dark lord
when he begins gathering said rings of
power too
and even possesses one of the three
elven rings to boot
at one point elrond's home oregaion is
destroyed by sauron's armies
and the elven lord retreats northward
where he establishes his own elven
stronghold
a place he names imladris otherwise
known as
rivendell elrond's new fortress holds
out against sauron and remains a key
rallying point for the free peoples of
middle earth for
thousands of years to come elrond also
plays a leading role in the last
alliance
and remains a dedicated warrior in the
struggle against
sauron as such he's bound to have a
pivotal role in amazon's prequel series
legolas greenleaf is one of the most
important yet underdeveloped characters
in all of tolkien's mythology
despite being a key member of the
fellowship of the ring
no one's quite sure how old he is or
just what he had really been up to
before the original trilogy kicked off
at the end of the day though this could
end up providing an unexpected boon for
the team at amazon studios
the lack of backstory or history for the
iconic elven prince
offers up a great opportunity to work
him directly into the primary narrative
without throwing things off from the
source material
now it's worth pointing out that this
has been done before
with mixed results
so yeah legolas role in the hobbit
wasn't exactly a success
but with a little bit of respect and
restraint amazon could nonetheless work
him into their story
and cement his status as a useful
through line across the ages of middle
earth's history
hobbits might well be the most
recognizable aspect of tolkien's story
but strangely enough
they're nowhere to be found prior to the
third age
in fact they don't even arrive in their
homeland of the shire until sixteen
hundred years
after the second age ends although a
bunch of elves do occupy
the same area for a while during that
particular era
sadly this means that any meaningful
part played by the good-hearted
hairy-footed people
will have to take place in flash
forwards unless the show eventually
progresses into the third age itself
but that hasn't stopped elijah wood from
voicing his willingness to cameo in the
show
if they're willing to work in a role for
him he already did exactly that in the
hobbit films
appearing in a scene that jumps forward
in time before the main story got
rolling
if amazon's team does follow peter
jackson and framing their story around
the stories of the hobbits
it's bound to make a lot of fans very
happy indeed
after all who doesn't want to see the
shire again
the dead marshes are a pretty freaky
place this
swampy haunted marshland lies to the
northwest of mordor
stretching for miles and miles in every
direction
this is the place where frodo sam and
gollum journey through on their way to
mordor
and it's also where frodo has a rather
unpleasant encounter with the ghostly
apparitions of some fallen warriors
eventually the trio find their way out
of the swamps and arrive at the black
gate
leaving this strange and unsettling
chapter firmly in the rearview mirror
so just where did these haunted swamps
come from well
fans of the books will know that the
wetlands used to be much smaller and
considerably less creepy
however a huge battle was fought there
at the end of the second
age during the war of the last alliance
over time
the swamp spread out swallowing up the
graves of the fallen warriors
including orcs elves and men alike
soon the marshes had grown into a dark
haunted wasteland
one that was inspired by tolkien's own
experiences during the battle of the
psalm
but the growth of the dead marshes isn't
just a deeply fascinating and unexplored
part of the middle earth story
it's also yet another way that amazon
could connect the events of their show
with the adventures of frodo and the
fellowship
the ruins on top of weathertop create
the backdrop for one of frodo's most
harrowing adventures
in the fellowship of the ring apparently
abandoned by aragorn
and facing an attack from the nazgul
frodo and his hobbit friends seek
protection by retreating to the ruins on
the crest of the hill of weathertop
there they're attacked by five ring
wraiths and frodo is stabbed with a
poisoned blade
before aragorn arrives in the nick of
time to save them
it turns out that that ruin isn't just a
heap of rubble though
they're actually the remains of a
fortress that was originally built
thousands of years earlier
when aragorn's numenorean ancestors
arrived in middle-earth
and established two new sister kingdoms
gondor in the south
and arnor in the north weathertop is
part of the kingdom of arnor
and the hill initially had a tower built
on top of it which acted as a key
fortress of the northern kingdom
not only is the fortress important but
it was also home to one of the seven
palantiri the same stones that sauruman
and sauron eventually steal
and use to communicate in the lord of
the rings weathertop becomes a much
bigger deal in the third age
but it could nonetheless make a welcome
return during the events of amazon
series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one